I have taken the master race sun breaker
Titan I'm gonna be rolling with a hand
cannon a sniper rifle and the subclass
will walk through it first here i'll
just show you guys what it is and what i
like the most fusion grenades from the
Warlocks have made the return I know
classic so many people love those the
new the new grenade the thermite grenade
it throws a burning line of fire for it
that's what i'll be using it's really
fun to use and incendiary grenade for
the jumps I'm sorry Titans no bling
today I'm still holding hope but that's
your usual jump with increased control
height catapult and then you're super
hammer of Sol which is Thor simulator
2015 it's amazing bring down here you
just you threw out a fiery hammer you
have different perks this one Elijah no
throw more Hamish because who doesn't
like more hammers simple decision more
hammers and this way sort of like
shoulder charge but this time you make
an exploding fire a bunch of times ah
super fun I will however be using this
new mechanic called sunspots and so
every time I throw out that sunspot will
appear in the gun and I'll show you how
that works later my melee sunstrike
burnin is the heavy solar male a strike
I'm gonna be using melting point this is
by the way guys start using a super good
your buddies will love you use this on
TV and everything hit this with the boss
and it weakens them for everybody doing
damage on for a little while it's super
good thermal vent you can also when they
explode great sun spots so if you want
to go to that ol skill tree you can do
that and Stroke the forge an interesting
name you said before it oh ok that's
like stroke the forge really but
different Oh anyway yeah your your codex
and the whatnot next your hammers soul
will seek your enemies really fun for
PvP enemies felt better him explode and
chaining parasitics would but i will be
using enemies felled by your fight grant
you but agility and reload speed so
using a hammer of Sol suddenly got all
these stacks super fun facing by the
flames
and codex next when super energies full
grenade melee abilities recharge twice
as fast so it's sort of a trade-off you
can keep your super but if you do I'm
going to in male age come back so it's
up to you this one I really like for PvP
killing somebody with a fire regenerates
your health so every time you kill some
with a hammer it regenerates your health
and then the whole mechanic that I've
time out with a sunspot when standing in
a sunspot you gain an over shield and
your hammers will last longer so I throw
a hammer down on the ground I stand in
that and range fiery death on everybody
so you're totally building here for sun
spots because you really love them here
yeah it's really good for PVE to you
just hold down a spot even PvP light
control makes you being really useful
yeah all that out of act and then lastly
the artifact which didn't get a cover
last week I have the radagast blade and
so what it will do is it's not actually
cosmetic so on your your character you
won't see it however as you'll see from
everybody else it does play into your
character and for instance mine so
amalias have a chance to generate or
when killing a minion of the darkness so
it works to your strength mm-hmm it
comes straight does it come to start
yeah
you